[Musique]
montceau a ravi de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat tout de
suite le sommaire c'est l'un des fléaux
de l'été la noyade première cause de
mortalité chez les moins de 25 ans le
département des yvelines n'échappe
malheureusement pas à ce phénomène pour
tenter de l'enrayer le gouvernement a
lancé un grand plan d'actions avec
notamment des cours gratuits de natation
alors ces mesures sont-elles suffisantes
c'est le débat du jour pour en parler
deux invités ce soir bruno mauger
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes des dirigeants
du club aqua net vallée de chevreuse à
chevreuse ou fait partie de l'un des
sept clubs de natation aigrinois
affiliés à la fff a proposé le
dispositif j'apprends à nager on en
parlera bien sûr en détail avec vous au
cours de cette émission
en face de bougie rend que bonsoir vous
êtes le président du comité
départemental 78 de la fédération
française de sauvetage et de secourisme
et merci en tout cas tous les deux
d'avoir accepté l'invitation alors un
chiffre pour débuter 597
c'est le nombre de personnes mortes par
noyade en france entre le 1er juin et le
30 septembre 2010 huit premières
questions que vous inspire ce chiffre
messieurs ce qu'ils appellent ce chiffre
c'est une difficulté à faire comprendre
aux personnes qu'il ya des précautions à
prendre lorsqu'on est au bord d'un étang
au bout d'un plan d'eau ce soit en
piscines privées en piscine publique ou
en accès libre
la difficulté est là aujourd'hui les
gens sont des vers les personnes sont
très à l'aise dans l'eau n'ont pas peur
de l'eau la canicule à l'année dernière
c'était pas la canicule comme on a eu
une période très chaude aussi mais le
souci c'est que les gens se baigner
n'importe où prennent prennent l'eau
comme un élément
source facile et sans danger alors qu'en
fait c'est tout le contraire c'est fini
c'est un lieu où on peut prendre
beaucoup de plaisir mais aussi qu'ils
avaient qui comporte certains risques
alors en trois ans les noyades
accidentelles estivales ont bondi de 30%
comme on va le voir avec ces chiffres
il y avait 1200 66 noyade accidentelle
en 2015 1649 en 2018 à quoi est ce dû à
votre avis cette augmentation de noyades
accidentelles ventes de précaution des
gens et puis enfin par rapport aux
enquêtes qu'on ait pu être faite sur ce
les catégories ce sont des gens qui
fondent inadvertance des gens qui font
des paris stupides et puis après une
méconnaissance du milieu aquatique
vous êtes d'accord et si j'ai leur
comportement finalement des ours et
comportementales preuve plupart du temps
alors quand on parle des adultes pour
les enfants c'est un autre problème
mais pour les adultes y en avait fallu
admettre de comportement il ya le côté
aussi été le côté festif et à l'alcool
et des substances plus ou moins on veut
pas dire interdites et de cumul de ces
substances et de l'alcool et de la
chaleur
ainsi thales baigner et des personnes ne
sont plus en état de le faire et
effectivement comme mon blog en fait au
niveau de la natation c'est après mme
comportementale principalement ces
dernières années on entend vous possible
ce terme de noyade sèche
pourquoi déjà on entend plus ce terme
ces dernières années on a l'impression
qu'avant ça n'existait pas pourquoi
maintenant parle plus de deux noyades
sèche le à thiès kolda d'évoquer le cas
il ya quelques temps c'est un phénomène
qui apparaît depuis depuis quelques
années effectivement on en parle est-ce
qu'on en parle parce que on a mis un
doigt un nom de sueur sur un phénomène
puisque c'est un phénomène qui n'est pas
simple et identifiés dans la mesure où
ça se produit pas immédiatement ça se
prouve que ça peut se produire jusque
dans les 72 heures après une inhalation
d'eau et la difficulté c'est de
raccrocher sa à une baignade précédente
c'est vrai que trois jours après on
passe pas forcément à la petite tasse
qu'on a bu dans une piscine ou dans un
étang on raccroche pas forcément à cette
noyade
le phénomène il est fait par contre il y
effectivement effectivement littré liés
puisque le fai dinel hainaut au niveau
des poumons
savourer tout ça valait une tasse à
comment dire une tasse ont tous un peu
et puis c'est réglé la difficulté c'est
que ces personnes qui sont fidèles de
noël sèche ça perdure dans le temps sur
plusieurs heures et ça se déclenche
plusieurs heures après et ça peut durer
jusqu'à 72 heures les enfants passent et
plus les enfants général de l'as monaco
on ne rencontre quand même beaucoup
beaucoup chez les enfants et il ya des
signes quand même à reconnaître ainsi si
vous avez déjà un enfant qui bon qui a
vu là tu as déjà d'une part ou qui vous
dit avoir bu la tasse et que derrière il
a une toux persistante il a des lèvres
bleues il a un peu montée de température
des difficultés respiratoires un peu
comme une crise d'asthme
alors qu'il n'est pas sympathique à
l'euro à l'origine donc ça ce sont des
signes qui doivent amener à consulter et
à contracter de 15 en urgence alors en
avril dernier le ministère des sports a
lancé un plan aisance aquatique pour
notamment habituer les enfants dès la
maternelle en fait à côtoyer les bassins
il ya cette piscine dans les yvelines
qui propose aussi le dispositif
j'apprends à nager alors ce sont des
cours gratuits pour les enfants de 4 à
12 ans bruno mauger la couenne est
vallée de chevreuse participe justement
à ces dispositifs que c'est la quatrième
année en retrait en quatrième année nous
avons commencé lundi dernier puisque
c'est une opération qui doit durer
normalement sur une dizaine d'heure
suivant le niveau des enfants on peut
couper ses heures en demie heure de
façon à pouvoir
alors ça va pas déjà prendre un âge est
réellement serpents les parents voient
pas les attendre à ce que l'enfant sache
faire des grôles du dow jones du
papillon au bout de dix heures
c'est prendre une aisance aquatique et
dans cette aisance aquatique sur ces 10
heures qui leur sont formés on parlait
aussi tout ce qui est précaution c'est à
dire qu'on va dire à l'enfant
tu rentres pas dans l'eau immédiatement
après cet exposé pendant quatre heures
au soleil un qui va d'abord commencer
par tout moyen qui peut qui va adapter à
tout environnement
et puis la première des choses qu'on va
leur apprendre c'est surtout ne pas
nager avec des lunettes
alors pourquoi parce que les parents
commencent à se mettre en retrait
redisons vrai mais moi mon enfant le
club a eu ce but les yeux le problème
dans un accident c'est que l'enfant il a
couru près d'une piscine privée il a
couru et au bord de la mer il est resté
dans son soutien sous surveillance
pendant un certain temps il va tomber à
l'eau donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est que
avec ce système sans lunettes
l'enfant arrive à se repérer dans l'eau
arrive à se mettre sur le dos et savoir
appeler au secours voilà ce que sais-je
apprend à nager
jabour à nager c'est que je m'habitue
déjà dans un premier temps à ce que
c'est que ce monde aquatiques
ça c'est pour les plus jeunes puisque là
on commence à partir de 4 ans et 6 ans à
la peau neuve et les chevreuse comme on
est sur des grands bassins donc on fait
à partir de 6 ans 6 en 12 ans
l'opération s'est surtout pouvoir à ce
qu'un jeune puisse rentrer en sixième en
connaissant le monde aquatique 12 ans
qu'est ce qui se passe gens rentrent en
sixième je donne dénudées je me retrouve
en maillot de bain voilà je me sens pas
à l'aise et où qu'est ce que je vais
faire j'aimerais avoir une autorisation
d'exemption voilà il ya pâte à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que la personne n'aura
jamais fait natation durant toute sa
scolarité puisque derrière tout ça il ya
quand même une scolarité il ya un
enseignement qui est fait il ya un autre
sentiment qui peut être fait c'est à
dire soit par des particuliers soit par
une inscription dans un club
là c'est le but aussi pour nous c'est de
se faire connaître au niveau de notre
club et puissiez de récupérer par la
suite un des adhérents
bon c'est pas notre rôle premier notre
rôle premier c'est vraiment faire
découvrir le milieu aquatique
et puis arrive et retrouver une aisance
fort sympathique gilleron que pensez
vous de ce dispositif très bien parce
que c'est un très bon lire ça permet à
des enfants qui vivent le monde dans
l'année ne pourrait pas fréquenter les
établissements demain puisque ça a quand
même un coup main de tous
c'est un coup au niveau de l'entrée là
le fait de le faire gratuit ça peut être
intéressant
est-ce que ça touche les bonnes
personnes ça c'est une autre histoire
est ce qu'on touche les personnes qui en
ont réellement pas digéré tout le monde
en a besoin mais ce qu'on touche les
personnes qui sont les plus et plus
démunis en termes de présence dans le
milieu aquatique
après par contre c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant parce que pour pour les
clubs ça permet déjà de faire peut-être
peut-être attirer un petit peu vers les
écoles de natation puisqu'il ya un
groupe intégré dans des piscines
puisqu'on travaille forcément toujours
des piscines il y avait un gros
partenariat qui se fait entre les clubs
de natation et les maîtres-nageurs le
drop sims et les ménages auront une
vocation d'apprendre à nager dans un
premier temps et souvent cédé souvent
les enfants qui sont intéressés glisse
vers les écoles de natation en ailleurs
déjà une base la date à voir et profite
à près de l'entraînement l'entraînement
dispensé par les dirigeants des queues
donc s'il ya un vrai patron de
partenariat est le fait d commencé de le
faire commencer tôt c'est intéressant on
a encore beaucoup de l'école mais
finalement l'apprentissage de la
natation pardon c'est le rôle de qui
finalement d'école des parents et deux
c'est tout le monde à l'heure actuelle
quand vous me donner des chiffres
importants au niveau des noyades
on va arriver enfin on est arrivé autant
d'accidents noyade que accidents de la
route
donc un accident de la route vous
plaisent c'est bien par un auto écoles
enfin vous passez par toute une
formation la natation c'est pareil il y
à une formation à faire et c'est à
chacun de prendre ses responsabilités et
savoir que un jour ou l'autre on peut se
retrouver sur le bord d'une piscine
privée bord de la mer pour un adulte
voilà ce qui s'est passé dernièrement
pendant la canicule vous avez un adulte
qui prend le pari pour épater sa copine
de traverser la seine à la nage la
seigne et des courants il n'est pas
arrivé jusqu'à sa copine quoi justement
parlant d'accident mortel la semaine
dernière un homme de 21 ans s'est noyé
dans l'étang débauche hr1 où la baignade
d'ailleurs été interdite dans cet étang
du coup la ville a lancé une campagne
d'affichage choc qu'on voit s'afficher à
l'écran est ce que selon vous ce type de
campagne peut faire prendre conscience
des dangers de la baignade toute façon
ça vaut pas de mauvais
moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'ennuie dans ce
genre de campagne c'est non pas le
message qui est passé c'est que les gens
non ça n'arrive qu'aux autres
les autres ne sont pas bons le voc n'ont
pas l'habitude des autres ne savent pas
nager les autres les autres les autres
et de l'autre vous prenez n'importe qui
même ce que ça sur la route l'accident
c'est toujours la faute de l'autre en un
moteur qui tombe c'est forcément une
info de quelqu'un d'autre personne qui
se noie c'est parce que la sécurité
n'est pas assurée par ce que le plan
d'eau n'est pas équipé parce qu'aussi il
dans quelques jours la faute de
quelqu'un personne aujourd'hui enfin
très peu en tout cas se disent je dois
prendre mes responsabilités je dois me
prémunir je dois faire attention
je donne des conseils à mes enfants et à
mes ados surtout amusé à dos entendu
dire qu'ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes et
j'essaie de leur expliquer que c'est
dangereux
la difficulté est là donc le rôle des
parents est primordial puisque les
acteurs comme les mecs soient les
maîtres nageurs ou les dirigeants
qu'elle ne reçoive des enfants mais si
les parents derrière n'ont pas fait un
travail pour leur expliquer qu'ils la
dangerosité et qu'en même temps le fait
de venir dans un club on dans une
piscine c'est pour apprendre quelque
chose c'est pas juste pour se baigner
pour se tremper il ya un gros travail à
faire là dessus donc la clé finalement
pour éviter les noyades c'est la
prévention c'est l'ambition et des
conseils pour bien réagir face
malheureusement une oie gatti on voit
quelqu'un à cet été si on va à la plage
ou si on va dans un étang où la baignade
est interdite et où un point d'eau on
voit que quelqu'un qui était en
difficulté comment comment il faut
réagir finalement la première parce que
en tant que choriste quand même ses plus
importants la première des choses c'est
déjà pas se dire je sais nager et
d'aller porter secours à la personne
surtout si on est seul c'est déjà très
mal vu parce que la personne qui va
aller porter secours va se noyer ou
fortes chances qu'à se noie avec toute
personne donc la première des choses
c'est se protéger par soi même
alerter mais ça c'est surtout important
c'est alerté en fait tout est
effectivement c'est exactement là où je
voulais en venir c'est qu'en fait voir
une noyade
voir quelqu'un se noyer c'est bien il
faut agir de façon il faut faire quelque
chose peut-être lancer une bouée sienne
des bouées à disposition s'il ya du
matériel expression mais en tout cas
prévenir si on n'est pas capable soi
même d'aller récupérer une victime ça
nécessite un entraînement et là on est
bien placé pour savoir ce que nous
formons des bénaissa toute l'année
c'est sa demande à une technicité
seulement un apprentissage
maintenant si on se sent si on est sûr
évalue ses capacités à aller chercher
quelqu'un comme le disait ensemble et on
va se retrouver avec deux victimes au
lieu d'une par contre ne pas sortir son
portable pour faire un film et un slam
en disant ouais les copains vous avez vu
il ya un gars qui est en train de se
noyer nom est allé prévenir ça serait
carrément que intéressant il ya en effet
des qui est toujours des sauveteurs à
proximité et si c'est une tâche qui
n'est pas surveillée et bien à prévenir
les secours simplement et au moins
attendre et dire voilà c'est là-bas pour
montrer au monde la direction si on
n'est pas capable et on va pas se mettre
en danger inutilement alors c'est la fin
de cette émission a déjà merci en tout
cas d'avoir accepté l'invitation
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
émission émission bien sûr que vous
pouvez retrouver sur notre site tv à 78
points comme également toutes les autres
émissions 7,8 débat à 2 cette saison je
vous souhaite à tous d'excellentes
vacances
[Musique]